[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and my
challenge for this video is to talk
about
usb
and to keep it somewhat interesting and
also to get a point across so usb is
universal serial bus keyword being
universal this full-size usb-a has been
around for years but our devices are now
getting too small and too powerful
honestly to keep using this huge legacy
port so it's time to usb see all the
things we're slowly closing in on a day
where we can go to work or go on
vacation and just bring one cable and
one charger just one thing to charge our
laptop our tablets our phones everything
but we're just not quite there yet so
knowing that we're on our way towards
usb type-c for everything and actually
ever since the macbook pro review people
have been asking well if we want to stay
ahead of the curve if we don't want to
get left behind we got to get stuff
that's good now so what are the best usb
type-c accessories available right now
this video is for those so a normal
thing you've probably used at some point
is a flash drive a full-size usb flash
drive obviously but if devices in the
future are all going to use usb type-c
instead you're going to want a usb
type-c flash drive actually sandisk
takes this a step further and has made
this which is a regular usb c flash
drive on one end and a full size usb on
the other end and it's two different
connectors but it's the same drive so
same files same storage same everything
just expands compatibility so that
should help bridge the gap for someone
living in like say 2017. i'll leave a
link to this and everything else i talk
about right below that like button so we
all have regular headphones and we've
all probably seen wireless headphones
and even lightning headphones i made a
video all about those but what we
haven't seen that much of is usb type-c
headphones mostly because there haven't
been that many devices to drop the
headphone jack and just have usb type-c
moto z
so until then i wouldn't expect to see
that many but when that keeps happening
in 2017 i'm telling you it's going to
happen now we're going to start to see
more usb type-c headphones so until then
this is the one and only pair of usbc
headphones i've found obviously they're
earbuds so if you don't like earbuds
you're not going to like these but
hopefully there should be way more in
the next year i'm also hoping that
wireless charging becomes much more
popular than it has been because you
kind of want to still be able to charge
and listen to music at the same time
anyway one of the bigger downsides of
moving to usb type c was actually the
loss of magsafe charging in the new
macbook pros they all use usb type-c to
charge so there's no more magsafe
luckily griffin has come to the rescue
and they've made this usb type-c magsafe
replacement that accomplishes the same
effect if you don't mind always having
this little nub always sticking out of
your computer it works the same way it's
not perfect and sometimes if you yank it
straight off it takes both parts out of
your computer but it's still better than
having that cable drag your laptop off
your desk and there's also car chargers
right so right now they're all full-size
usb but again the move to the future
will have way more usb type c so you can
get your hands on something like this
nomad makes this usb type c car charger
and as a bonus it has a 3 000 milliamp
hour battery built in so even when the
car is off you can charge up so that is
really convenient and i expect to see
more stuff like that and then battery
banks are also slowly starting to
migrate too so anker is a pretty popular
manufacturer they've made one of my
favorite already this is a 20 000
milliamp hour battery plenty of power
that you can just slip in your backpack
or a bag and it can easily charge up a
couple tablets or smartphones or even
your usb type-c laptop several times
over so all these battery and power
accessories are actually doing pretty
well all they have to do is just switch
to usb type c to keep pushing power
through that cable but the things that
have to get a little more complex to
push data through that cable as well
that's where it starts to get a little
tricky so there's a couple usb type-c
mobile ssds that i've found and these
are a pretty big deal if you're a video
editor if you're on the go working with
really big files then you'll start to
use these a lot and the glyph was pretty
promising but it started to have some
issues for multiple people including me
on the new macbook pro so right now the
best one i've found is the samsung t3
i've got a pair of them they go up to a
terabyte and speeds are pretty great the
cable is nice and short
so for mobile editing this makes a great
addition to the setup and then at the
desktop i was waiting for this one for a
while but this is the promise pegasus 3
r8 it's a desktop raid array this
happens to be the one with eight hard
drives in it and each hard drive is six
terabytes in raid so this is a 48
terabyte tower of storage so as of three
videos ago i'm now keeping all the raw
video now fun fact for years i was not
doing that i was just keeping the final
video file and throwing away all of the
raw video footage because 8k raw is just
a lot now i'm just going to start
keeping it all but even as good as usb
type c is at the end of the day
sometimes you're just going to need
another port you know you might need
hdmi or you might need ethernet and so
port expanders like this dell one are
going to be good for you or even from
kickstarter the hyperdrive which you've
probably seen it takes one or two usb
type-c ports but then adds them back and
gives you a bunch of others this one
gives you hdmi and sd card slot and a
micro sd card slot etc it fits the
macbook pro aesthetic pretty well it
comes in the right color so silver or
gold or space gray and if you don't mind
again having a little something sticking
out of your computer this can likely
solve the biggest problems we have with
the macbook pro port situation this is
not one of those fading trends like usb
type c is gaining momentum and is going
to be everywhere to stay it's not like
3d tvs which kind of rose and then fell
or even like the sort of modular thing
that we're seeing sort of spark in and
out this is definitely here to stay and
you're going to want to be on board when
this becomes the true
universal again usb type c should be
everywhere so that's been it hope this
helps hope you enjoyed a video about usb
and feel free to share it for others who
you think should know about the feature
that's coming thanks for watching talk
to you guys in the next one
peace